ومع الحديث عن المفاوضات بدات تخرج من
اكياس توقعات بقربي نهايه هذه الحرب كيف
التفاصيل معك يا طاهر
بحلول الربيع المقبل واستعاده المزيد من
الاراضي الاوكرانيه نائب وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني لوف قال ان قوات بلاده قد تصل
الى شبه جزيره القرم التي تسيطر عليها
روسيا منذ 2014 بحلول اعياد الميلاد اي في
ديسمبر الا ان الامر سيحتاج بعض الوقت قبل
نهايه الحرب في اوكرانيا كما لم يستبعد
هافري لواضح احتماله وقوع ما يعرف بنظريه
البشعه السوداء داخل روسيا اي الاحداث
المفاجئه والتي لا يمكن التنبؤ بها في
الاشهر المقبله في اشاره ربما الى تطور
سياسي غير متوقع قد يؤثر على الكرملين
مباشره
ياسر
السوداء
فرونا الى منطقه همم كرسنودار الروسيه
المجاوره وسط مخاوف من ان اوكرانيا ستتحرك
قريبا لاستعاده المنطقه قبل ذلك قالت
وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه الجمعه ان
الوحدات الروسيه قامت بحفر خنادق جديده
بالقرب من حدود شبه جزيره القرم كما غرد
قبل اسبوع بن هات جزء القائد العام السابق
لجيش الامريكي في اوروبا قال ان منظومه
الصواريخ هايمارس ستبدا العمل قريبا من
خرسان ما يعني ان شبه جزيره القرد تقع ضمن
نطاق الصواريخ عبر ايضا عن قناعته بان هذا
يمكن ان يضعف الدفاعات الروسيه بينما يسعى
الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد للسيطره على
مدينتي مريوطل وميلي بول بحلول يناير ثم
تبدا المرحله الحاسمه من الحمله استعاده
شبه جزيره القرم
[موسيقى]